bonjour monsieur depardieu j'aimerais
beaucoup vous interviewez alors voilà
j'ai 15 ans je veux pas night is là et
dit tu veux faire quoi dans la vie de
journaliste je dis oui c'est vraiment un
métier de merde il m'a dit t'as pas été
très bon mais ça a été ponctuel
on a loupé le feu rouge avec mon
anecdote de vue grand-père là à là
c'est un agent immobilier je fais
découvrir paris s'étaient donné rendez
vous ici au point virgule parce que
c'est la première salle dans laquelle
j'ai eu la chance de jouer et ce qui est
une chance de ouf parce que c'est un
écrin incroyable que tu es tellement
près des gens que tu es dans la tête des
gens du coup quand tu fais une blague t
dans la tête des gens et que tu sais
tout de suite si nous c'est de la merde
ou sinon ça va c'est pas mal
terminée tant tirs
c'est une ans et que tu te penches comme
une autruche
sa leçon l'entente autan juste là
[Musique]
j'allais avec mes amis nous week-end un
rer à paris et je venais vraiment
vraiment à essayer d'aller à tous les
événements d'humour pour parler aux
humoristes rencontrer les attachés de
presse mes trucs et leur dire que je
fais un peu des blagues de saab outrance
et où il disait mais qu'est ce qui fait
évidemment j'ai envie rencontre est de
plus en plus de gens et on m'a proposé
des soirées j'ai tenté des trucs un peu
sur scène et ça s'est un peu fait comme
ça quoi j'étais vraiment je pense dans
la catégorie art cela que j
[Musique]
allais
ça c'est du jeu quand j'avais 15 ans je
l'avais contacté sur internet une agence
d'attaché de presse mais après un stage
et j'arrive je fais mon stage pendant
une semaine et c'était trop cool et à la
fin du stage avant de me barrer j'ai mis
une petite clé usb j'ai récupéré tous
les contacts de lagence et du coup mais
dans mon portable encore aujourd'hui via
à zidane booba et donc j'avais le numéro
2 par dieu et je l'appelle à un jour
pour essayer de l'interviewer tu vois je
l'appelle hé il décroche moi je
m'attendais pas à chaque fois je me
prenais devant j'ai laissé des messages
et où elle avait décroché dit oui sous
avec cette voiture et je tiens je suis
dans la cuisine there chez moi et à ma
mère qui fait des pâtes et uri celui-là
bonjour monsieur depardieu j'aimerais
beaucoup vous interviewez alors voilà
j'ai 15 ans je veux le pana y ait de
tesla est dit tu veux faire quoi dans la
vie de journaliste je dis oui c'est
vraiment un métier de merde désolé pour
toi mais je répète ce qu'il a dit et il
me dit tu veux pas faire de tri xénon et
gdba
c'est pas j'aimerais bien peut-être
architectes emma dire mais ça c'est bien
ça c'est super et m'a donné plein de ce
peut pas le faire trop longtemps
puisqu'après du cuir de veau ce soir
c'est le mec qui arrive avec désolé j'ai
limité depardieu pendant une minute
trente valeurs et je suis cuit et du
coup elle m'a et janry me donne plein de
noms d'architectes japonais et me dit on
s'appelle demain on va parler et
raccroche et je suis comme ça dans ma
cuisine je vais sur l'ordinateur de la
famille je tape les noms et tout et le
lendemain je le rappelle est on en
discute et vraiment pendant vraiment 20
à 30 minutes on discute d'architecturé
japonaise avec depardieu et la femme dit
je sens bien que t'as pas envie d'être
journaliste se sont contentés de faire
du beau si tu veux faire du bouffey du
boat excuse pas
[Musique]
avec paris on se voyait dans des
restaurants et on écrivait du stand-up
et m'appellent anyway joue à bobino
vient et où j'arrive est vraiment une
heure avant son spectacle qui me dit
c'est toi qui fait la première partie je
dis ah bon mais moi à oui et je monte
sur scène dit tu fais par contre juste
avant il me dit tu fais les cinq minutes
qu'on a écrit ce week-end et où je monte
je m'éclate la gueule et en sortant il
m'a dit je savais que ça allait mal se
passer mais je voulais voir si tu as les
tenir et il m'a dit était resté cinq
minutes il m'a dit t'as pas été très bon
mais ça a été ponctuée
le procès un stop c'est le surf ati
c'est un comedy club rue berger où on
travaille les comedy club c'est vraiment
le lieu où on teste des passages la
première idée la mairie elle est trop de
neuf encore
travailler la première est née
le lieu est secrète à parois de films et
donc nous ce qui est parfait on peut
tester tout ce qu'on veut taper dessus
mais pas leur prendre des photos par là
de sortir de portable rien de tout ce
qui se passe à l'intérieur et sénateur
[Musique]
j'aime bien y jouer avant de faire des
spectacles parce que je trouve que c'est
cool tu testes des trucs et après tu
fais le truc dont tu es sûr tu vois les
trois quarts c'est devenu bien de merde
que on pourra pas savoir s'ils sont bien
ou pas bien avant d'user fait dans ce
genre de lieu après qu'ils aient fait
sur scène les gens font non
obligés d'avoir vécu énorme bide quand
il fait ça un jour j'ai fait un passage
à la cigale
je me suis bien éclaté maras sept
minutes de bon gros silence à la cigale
rester à jour 50
au tout remis en question j'avais un peu
peur de quitter la télévision pour faire
de la scène tu commences demandant les
communiquent leurs cantines commence la
scène et du coup tu passes de la télé à
des câbles dans le milieu de fin fond de
paris demandant si personne c'est un peu
genre l'un vers une carrière s'est un
peu fait benjamin button mais de
l'acteur de la carrière je crois que le
chiffre c'est que en moyenne un artiste
avant qu'ils commencent à remplir des
salles ça mais sept ans tient un stand
up et repart donc winston de plus ces
chiffres il est effrayant mais en vrai
c'est un métier de longue haleine c'est
un marathon
[Musique]
you
moi j'ai entre par là bas dans le
spectacle les ans il s'est installé il
annonce non ils arrivent par là
et je sors par là aussi
venez visiter ses loges
regarde c'est encore un peu triste parce
que j'en arrivais ya pas longtemps de
théâtre et un petit tableau
est là dedans il ya écrit tout mon
spectacle dans les lettres
la touche spectacle peut dire n'importe
quelle phrase tu vas perdre en spectacle
bah oui c'est ça montre le bha oui
[Musique]
oui la bouche
c'est cool il pourrait notre au soir
[ __ ] les gens étaient trop marrant les
gens étaient trop marrant merci brut
pour cette belle journée en votre
compagnie
[Musique]